you
so tokyo students apart from looking for
a an obvious facility with the tools
that I need to use the math since I sure
what do you look for in the students
that you teach because you will teach
two things the first is it's a good mind
and the second good motivation to study
economics they have those two will make
it perfect is better i think i think in
any subject so when students commit to I
asked my advice especially especially
Cyprien Greek students have become a bit
of a father figure B&C I think the
current they say oh my you know my
parents think that would do you know I
said to them you know the advice always
make things like you really be motivated
in studying what you're studying and if
you have a good mind which usually
admissions people make sure that whether
it's not me that doesn't mind a they
succeed in what they are doing I think
that's economics is not like art who you
might where you might look for a natural
talent it's not like poetry literature
things it's more of a scientific subject
I think that have a slightly different
take and this is more in the small than
the large because what you're saying I
agree with I did graduate admissions for
decades it's one of the things that is
happily stopped because it's a big job
we normally get over 800 applications
for 20 places so it's quite a job but
what you can judge for for incoming
graduate students you can often tell if
they have a good mind and you can often
tell not quite as often whether they
have good motivation but there are
certain ingredients and creativity that
will determine whether they're OK or
pretty good or very good and that's very
hard to measure ahead of time and it's
something unnecessarily
grades it exactly exactly so there's
something else which you don't you often
don't find out until people are working
on their dissertations and you discover
they're just missing some element of the
mental makeup that will limit that can
still be successful Economist's and do
things but in our program almost
everyone coming in is planning to become
an academic then they get more
interested in something or they decide
it will work better with something else
but the skill that generates successful
academic career involves some other
ingredients than just being smart and
it's interesting to reflect on it and
almost impossible to measure ahead of
time and that's too often even after
they calculate me huh yes sir package of
programs a new brother for graduates now
I've taught for 45 years in a major arts
program it does not have a business
program so we have a quarter of our
College majoring in economics and I
often tried to advise some of them that
that may not be what they should be
doing particularly if they're following
their parents advice I and the this move
to success for for many people arises to
do something that you're good at and
become accomplished at it and once that
happens the world's open to you and once
be able to communicate number one
and have a track record of sort and I
tell them become a philosophy major if
that's what you want to do if you do
well at it the best business school in
the country will open their doors to
you